today I'll tell you how to use
sunflowers to prove non-adaptive data
structure bonds and this is joint work
with a new probe so let's get started so
okay so the question that we interested
in is like designing data structures
that maintain subsets of numbers from 1
to N and you want the data structure to
support insertions and also in our
median computation and predecessor
computation so these are the operations
that are interested in and that we would
like to understand what the optimal data
structure is for like supporting these
operations ok good so for the rest of
the talk the universe is the set of
numbers from 1 through n and just as a
reminder predecessor of X is nothing but
the largest element in your set that's
at most X ok for example in the set s
here the predecessor of 15 is 13 okay
good so the plan for the talk is first
show some upper bounds that solves this
problem and also discuss the time
complexities and then formally define
what the model is then discuss ourselves
and show proof ok good so one basic data
structure that you can use to solve this
problem is just have a Saturday along
with the size of the set and here
insertions are expensive they can take
time n but the median computation is
very quick and the predecessor
computations take log and ok and another
way to represent your set is just by
writing down the indicator of xref a set
in this case the insertions are very
quick but median and predecessor
computations are expensive ok
and another data structure simple data
structure we can think of is the
predecessor array essentially an array
of length n where the ith entry stores
the predecessor of I and here the
predecessor computations are very fast
but insertions and medians are expensive
ok so here you kind of like see gap in
the sentence like one of the operations
is very expensive the other one is very
quick so the natural thing to try are
like for such problems is the
research data structure so here you can
do all these operations and order login
time so let me just describe what the
data structure is so you have a balanced
binary tree for depth log N and you have
n leaves and each leaf is associated
with an element in the universe and the
leaves being empty says the element is
not present if it's not empty the
element is present okay and every
internal node stores the number of
elements in the left subtree and the
number of elements in the right subtree
with along with the maximum of the left
subtree and the maximum of the I said
small lot someone recently pointed out
that like this is slightly different
from the usual binary search trees that
you might have seen where like there are
no empty leaves usually associated but
I'm like writing it this way for some
reason that'll be clear so okay so for
example if you'd like to perform an
insertion you just go to the leaf that
corresponds to the element v here for
example and then just walk up to the
root and make sure change all the cells
entries to make sure the invariants are
satisfied okay
and here it's again easy to see that you
can do median and lag in time because
you go to the root and then you recurse
on the left or right depending on the
number of elements and the left subtree
on the right subtree okay and again so
if you'd like to do the predecessor
configuration you go to the leaf that
corresponds to the predecessor that you
want to compute and then walk up to the
root and find the node that's closest to
the leaf which has a non-empty left
subtree and in this case it's this
particular node which has like 13 and
you just output the maximum in that okay
and clearly all these operations you
know require order log n time okay and
next question to ask is log in best sir
can you do any better so this is a very
nice data structure of YouTube and it
was there actually Sol's you know or
performs all these operations in order
log log n time okay and the key here I'm
not going to discuss the data structure
in detail but the key is in the case of
binary search trees at every step you we
divided the
universe into like two equal halves but
here you're going to like divide it into
square root n consecutive intervals and
then recur since at some level okay and
just that wouldn't work and you'll need
a oxidative structure on the side but
roughly that intuition should be good
enough and here the depth of this such a
tree would be like log log n which gives
the logarithm runtime okay so so we've
seen like a bunch of data structures so
let me formally define the model that we
work with it's the self up model that we
saw in the previous talk introduced by
Yau so the data structure is nothing but
a collection of cells in memory that
stores your data and it usually comes
with two algorithms one is the update
algorithm and the other one is the query
algorithm so update algorithms typically
bring about changes to you or make
changes to your data and in our case
like insertions are like an update
operation and you can think of like what
the data structure does or the algorithm
does this reads the sequence of cells
and makes changes to them and yeah this
and the time or the update time is
defined to be the number of cells that
are accessed while performing the update
otherwise performing the insertion okay
similarly you can talk about query
algorithms which typically compute a
function of the data that you have and
in this case you can think of median
computation which is a query and you
gain like read a sequence of cells and
then output the answer and the time
again here is the number of cells that
are accessed you know while outputting
an answer so hopefully that's clear so
before we discuss fast work and our
results I will define the notion of what
non-adaptive inserts and like operations
mean so let me define it with respect to
insertions here so an insertion is
non-adaptive if the locations of all the
cells that are accessed while performing
the insertion just depends on the number
that's being inserted and that's not
different on the car
tens of the cells that it reads in the
process in the case of the binary search
tree that we saw like once you know that
it one insert five you know that you're
going to read only these cells that are
associated with the nodes on the path
from the leaf corresponding to Phi to
the root so this is clearly none of that
okay and the case of median was actually
adaptive because you had to make a
decision of whether to go recurse on the
left subtree of the right subtree
depending on the number of nodes that
you had a number of like elements on the
left subtree and the right children and
predecessors again we're a non adaptil
here and the vanity boys data structure
that i described both operations are
actually adapt so before i actually
discuss our results i just wanted to say
that you know this problem or the
question of proving dynamic data
structure bonds have been well studied
starting from the work of Redman slacks
but they show a lower bound of the farm
logon or log log n on the maximum of the
time true but from the query early
compute the query or perform the update
okay and as Casper mentioned in the open
problems session on Monday the
best-known lower bound that we have is
log N or lager again the whole squared
and yeah that's the state of art for
dynamic game flow once and in the case
of for non adaptive dynamic data
structures we know actually polymer
lower bounds and multiple interesting
problems like directed graph reach
ability and so on and this was done by
Joshua and Kasper so now let me go ahead
and discuss at ourselves so the first
problem we consider is like data
structures that allow deletions and
compute the minimum in this case when
the relations
and the minimum computations are
non-adaptive then you can show that the
time to perform the deletions plus the
time to compute the minimum is at least
log N or log log n okay
so in the case of median we show that
when both operations both insertions and
the median computation is not a tap to
you can show a lower bound of log N or
log log n on the sum of the time for
insertions and the time for million
computation and for non adaptive
insertions so we actually in fact we
prove something stronger so assuming
that only the insertions are non-arab -
you can show that the time to compute
the median is at least n to the power 1
over the time to compute to perform the
insertions ok in the case when both
operations are actually adaptive it's
actually open to proven a super constant
load born but I have to also remark that
I have worst case you know times in mind
when I say this because there are data
structures that's you know that performs
insertions and computes the median in
amortized order one time so for the
predecessors problem an independent work
of boninger Brodie and Kepler they
showed that the following trade-off
where either the when both insertions
and predecessor computations are non
adaptive you have that either the time
to insert is at least log n R the time
to compute the predecessors is like
login or loudly okay and this work will
show something stronger assuming that
only the predecessor computations are
non adaptive you can show that either
the time to compute the predecessor is
log in or loggin or the time for
insertions is at least n to the 1 over
the time to compute the processes
and in the case of adaptive inserts and
predecessor computations is a well
understood problem you know and we know
that the vanity was data structures
tight due to long list of works okay so
probably there's a good time to take
questions any questions on the results
okay so just okay forgot about this so
like just to compare like where these
parameters like the bit vector case we
saw that like the insertions being like
constant time you have that the median
computations were like linear so this
gives you like a polynomial or bound on
the time to compute the median when the
insertions are in constant time okay and
in the case of predecessor arrays when
like the predecessor computations are
constant time you have like a linear
upper bound and the lower bound says
you're like : oh then you have constant
time to complete the predecessors and
the binary search trees corresponds to a
setting where like both predecessor
computation and the insertions were like
log in or log log n and this is the vine
ambiguous structure no it's like it's
log log N
have any more questions
right so I should also mention that the
question of like computing median has
been studied in other models like
time-space trade-offs streaming
algorithms it was also considered in the
context of data structures in the
comparison model when they had like very
tight upper and lower bounds
good so I actually have about 15 minutes
so and I'll be able to show you the
complete proof of one of the theorems
and so we'll do that so I just want to
lick okay so let's start by I'll
describe like what the sunflower Lamas
are remind everyone of what the
sunflower Lamas
is this will be the key technical tool
that we use so what this says is if you
have a sequence of n sets where each set
is of size T then if you have the number
of sets to be large enough roughly like
P to the T then you can always find a
sunflower among them by a sunflower I
mean like you have subset of this
collection where Parrish intersections
are always the same and the thing to
note here is n is roughly P to the T
where T is size of each set and you will
actually be able to find a sunflower
with people's okay are like yeah so also
I should say that like it's not
something new like like sunflowers have
been used in like complexity a lot like
Winston's in the case of like Morton
circle or bonds now in fact they have
also been used in the context of data
structure or bonds in both like dynamic
and static data structure or bonds in
the bit probe model and we also applied
in a very similar way that it was used
before so the goal for the rest of the
talk is to prove the following theorem
where you're given a data structure
where you know that the where TI is the
time to perform the insertions and TM is
the time for the median and both of them
are non adaptive and you want to show a
lower bound of log and/or log again on
these operations okay so this will be
the goal for the rest attack I can go
slow please ask me questions if
something is not clear perfect so the
outline of the proof is going to be as
follows
first we'll come up with like a sequence
of sets where the end side
where n was the universe that we are
working with and I said is nothing but
the set of all cells that are accessed
while inserting the number I are that's
used while computing the median
then we'll use these end sets to find a
sunflower with roughly P petals where P
would be roughly n to the 1 over T where
T is the time for these computations and
then what we'll claim is you can just
look at the contents of the code to
encode a large random subset ok so
that's that will be the outline of how
the argument is compressing the idea is
that these subsidies too large to be
encoded so efficiently yes exactly
okay so okay so as before let me define
what the ID set was it was the set of
all cells that was accessed while
inserting the element I or the number I
are computing the median okay so now we
actually get a sunflower with P sets
without loss of generality you can
assume that these correspond to the
cells that are like the like these are
indexed by 1 through P and not worry
about because you just are you care only
about the median computation like the
rank of all these elements are going to
be preserved in this operation sorry
just to repeat what I meant to say was
like you have x1 through xn and you'll
find P sets in this collection which are
x i1 through x IP that form a sunflower
all I'm saying is where I 1 is less than
I 2 is less than IP just think of it as
1 through P and not worry about the
index okay so now pick set s that's a
uniformly random subset of the middle
one third elements that's exactly
between like P or 3 and 2 PI over 3 and
now use the data structure to perform
the insertions insert these numbers and
now you will actually have a bunch of
cells that are accessed and here like
when I've shared a petal it means that
that particular element was inserted and
some of the cells associated with it
we're like actually modified ok now the
claim is that the contents of the core
encode the set that you just inserted
so this is the key claim does anyone
have ideas at Lake
okay so let me tell you the proof it's
not too hard so we are going to use the
sunflower structure very crucially here
so the first key claim here is if you
actually look at any number that's not
in the middle one-third range if you
would like to insert this number now you
only need access to the core for
instance if you were to insert this
number two P over three plus one you
only need access to the core because you
know that all these cells that it
accesses that are outside the core were
never touched by the insertions that
were performed earlier okay so to
simulate these operations you just need
to know what the chorus okay this is
very powerful because now okay so okay
there's one more fact that we need to
use you know that all these sets excise
contained all the cells that were used
to compute the median so by just looking
at the core you should be able to also
compute the median so now you repeatedly
insert elements that are like in the
that are not in the middle one-third
range and keep computing the median and
this will help you recover to the
complete set saying it's like you just
need the core to compute the median of
the set s and now you add an element
that's like more than two P or 3 and
this will give you the element that's
like one away from the median in rank
that's to the right of the median when
you start the elements of s and you
insert one more element to get the
element greater than that and so on so
this way you will be able to recover all
the elements of s there are greater than
the median and now you can always
perform like keep adding numbers that
are less than P or 3/2 like they require
everything that's only performing the
operations that are like in your
sunflower note the other exactly so like
for the set X I to be well-defined
you need non adaptivity like like to
compute the median you know that you're
only gonna always access a fixed number
of cells and they are not going to
depend on the current contents so they
have to be percent inside the code
that's when an update is used
that's also used in the lake for the
insertions cases
okay
and now so this is good enough because
yeah the entropy of the set that you in
like inserted was like P or 3 and the
number of elements are like the number
of bits that you require to actually
encode the core is are like write down
the core is w times TI + TM where w is
the word length and each set is of size
at most e i + DM you know this is the
standard entropy argument and this
should tell you that TI + TM should be
at least fuel W and P was roughly n to
the power 1 over TI + t r this should
tell you that ta + TM is log in or log
log
yeah once I survived again why do it
certainly no no so in such okay so you
could touch something outside as well
but when you're inserting an element
that is not in the middle one third
range or when you're inserting element
that's not inserted before you only need
to know the core because no other cell
outside the core was ever touched and
that is like using the sunflower
structure like you have an inserting
this particular element like you the
elements that are like outside the core
will never touch base so they are like
this chain from every other
okay so hopefully like that was clear
any more questions okay perfect so this
gives you the log on or lager again bond
so I actually have few more minutes so
I'm gonna quickly tell you how to you
know get the stronger bound so when you
only assume that the insertions are
non-adaptive
in this case the median competitions can
be adaptive but if you get a stronger
lower bond where like the time to
compute the median is at least n to the
one hour time for insertions okay so
here we start like before where you
actually define the ID set to be the set
of all cells that were accessed while
inserting the number I and you'll again
find
sunflower among them and now instead of
so now what you'll argue is you'll
actually say that the median computation
since the insertions were non adaptive
it will help you not just compute the
median but it will also help you compute
the kid smallest element in the set okay
and then we know how to prove lower
bounce against Kate smallest queries
using the chronograph approach and then
we will use that so again let me quickly
tell you what the reduction is so you'll
again only look at a set or you pick a
random subset of the middle one third
elements and then the claim is once you
know the core so you insert the set and
once you know the core and size of the
set you can always find the kid smallest
element in time that is the same as time
to compute the median this is because as
before you know that you insert the set
s and a bunch of cells get you know are
like like petals get shaded now if you
would like to insert any element that is
not in the middle one-third range you
just need to know the core so you can
always like move the median to the kit
smallest because you know the size of
the set and just doing a asking for the
median or computing the median median
using the data structure is going to
recover the Kate smallest element free
anything outside is you get it for free
by just knowing the core and yeah you
can now compute the median to recover
any get smallest once you know the size
of the set it will be the 20 of compute
the median you access things that are
not in the core yes that is correct so
now yeah the argument is not complete so
this is says that the time to find the
kid smallest is the same as the time to
compute the median so I'm not claiming
that it reads the code but it's the same
so you can use ideas from like the
chronograph approach of fragments acts
and along with the reduction from
patrasche control where they show that
like to compute the kid smallest element
even in the adaptive case you have a log
in lower bound so plugging that in would
give you a lower bound of TI times at a
time for insertions times the product
the product of time for median is at
least log in or log log n but then we
actually claim something stronger this
is because you can actually open up the
proof of the chronograph approach and
then use the sunflower structure to
improve it and you get something
stronger so instead of just the products
being at least log and you'd like get a
column inside of it
the key idea isn't like reducing it to
create small s or like using the median
to compute the kid smallest and some
pretty pictures maybe I'll skip this
yeah so I'll just conclude with an open
problem where like as mentioned before
like in case of like worst case times
can you show a login sorry log log n
over some you know Polly in log log log
are some smaller factors on the when
both insertions and median computations
are adaptive and here like even in the
worst case like even like super constant
seems to be open and like nothing
special about media and you can also
think of like minimum or maximum but you
love to allow deletions otherwise the
problem is very easy
thank you did you consider a kind of
hybrid mod models with some had activity
but not yeah so we have some results
where like insertions are adaptive but
in the case of the median lower bond
like the median comes the queries are
like non adaptive sorry if a
predecessors queries are non adaptive
but updates are adaptive but in the case
of median you know updates are not after
but the query is a reductive alright I
was thinking more like you have to send
off batches of memory accesses at a time
well actually yeah I cannot we didn't
consider that yeah and I can't think of
anything on top of my head yeah
no questions
this place